E
BUNGEE JUMPS OFF A STEP STOOL,
PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
FOX NEWS ALERT, POTENTIAL MAJOR
BREAKTHROUGH IN THE MANHUNT FOR
BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
THE FBI CONFIRMING THAT THEY
HAVE WHAT APPEARS TO BE HUMAN
REMAINS AT FLORIDA WILDERNESS
PARK ALONG WITH PERSONAL ITEMS
BELONGING TO LAUNDRIE,
LAURA INGLE'S IS IN GABBY
PETITO'S TOWN WITH THE LATEST.
>> HEY, GREAT, NO CONFIRMATION,
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE HOPING TO
HEAR THE FBI SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
WHO THESE HUMAN REMAINS BELONG
TO, BUT WE DID NOT GET THAT IN
THE PRESS CONFERENCE MOMENTS
AGO.
BUT THE FBI GIVING US A
SIGNIFICANT UPDATE IN THE SEARCH
FOR BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CAUGHT OUR EAR AND THE PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS THAT THEY SAID
THAT BRIAN LAUNDRIE WAS A PERSON
OF INTEREST IN THE MURDER OF
GABBY PETITO.
THEY NEVER USE THAT LANGUAGE
BEFORE, THE FBI HOLDING THE NEWS
CONFERENCE ABOUT THE HUMAN
REMAINS THAT WERE FOUND TODAY.
LISTEN.
>> EARLIER TODAY, INVESTIGATORS
FOUND WHAT APPEARS TO BE HUMAN
REMAINS ALONG WITH PERSONAL
ITEMS SUCH AS A BACKPACK, A
NOTEBOOK BELONGING TO BRIAN
LAUNDRIE.
THESE ITEMS WERE FOUND IN THAT
AREA THAT UP UNTIL RECENTLY HAD
BEEN UNDERWATER.
>> SO FOX NEWS DIGITAL CATCHING
CHRIS AND ROBERTA LAUNDRIE AT
THE RESERVOIR EARLIER TODAY, A
SEARCH TEAM OVERHEARD TELLING
HIS PARENTS HE MIGHT'VE FOUND
SOMETHING.
TELLING POLICE HE HAD GONE FOR A
HIKE SEPTEMBER 13TH AND THEN
REPORTED HIM MISSING AFTER HE
DID NOT RETURN TO THEIR
NORTH PORT, FLORIDA, HOME FOR
SEVERAL DAYS.
CADAVER DOGS, A CORONER'S VAN,
INVESTIGATORS ALL AROUND THE
RESERVE TODAY, THE FBI
ANNOUNCING THAT THE AREA WILL
ONCE AGAIN BE CLOSE TO THE
PUBLIC AFTER IT WAS REOPENED TO
THE PUBLIC YESTERDAY.
I REACHED OUT TO THE FAMILY OF
GABBY PETITO AND THEIR ATTORNEYS
TO SAY THAT THE "GUTFELD" FAMILY
WILL NOT BE MAKING A COMMENT
TODAY AND DO NOT HAVE PLANS TO
DO SO IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
STANDING HERE TODAY AND BLEW
POINT COME AS YOU MENTION GABBY
PETITO'S HOMETOWN, A LOT OF
PEOPLE STILL AWAITING ANSWERS AS
WE ALL DO FROM THE FBI.
>> Greg: WE WILL TAKE IT
AROUND THE TABLE, I HAVE THE
FIRST QUESTION, THE LAUNDRIE
PARENTS DECIDED TO HELP WITH THE
INVESTIGATION LAST NIGHT,
SURPRISE, SURPRISE, THEY FIND
THE BODY THE NEXT DAY.
I'M ASSUMING IT IS HIM.
DID THEY KNOW WHERE HE WAS THE
WHOLE TIME?
NUMBER TWO IS IT POSSIBLE THEY
MADE A DEAL TO HELP FIND THE
BODY SO THEY WOULD NOT BE
CHARGED?
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WONDERING
WHAT THE ACTIVITY WAS WITH CHRIS
AND ROBERTO LAUNDRIE, THAT IS
THE KEY QUESTION.
WITH THE TIME FRAME THEY SAID WE
ARE DONE SEARCHING THE AREA, WE
WILL WRAP IT UP AND TAKE DOWN
THE YELLOW TAPE AND LET THE
PUBLIC COME IN AND THEN WE HAVE
THIS DEVELOPMENT TODAY, THE FBI
HAS BEEN TIGHT-LIPPED AS ALL OF
THE INVESTIGATORS ARE ON THE
CASE, AND AS YOU HAVE SEEN,
CHRIS AND ROBERTA LAUNDRIE AS
WELL.
>> Dana: ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO
MR. LAUNDRIE JOINED THE SEARCH,
DID THEY --
YOU PROBABLY DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THIS, BUT IT WOULD BE
CURIOUS IF THEY WENT TO THE
SPOT.
>> BUT THESE INVESTIGATORS ASKED
CHRIS LAUNDRIE TO TAKE THEM TO
AREAS THEY KNOW WE HAVE BEEN TO
BEFORE.
WHAT DID HE LIKE TO DO?
WE WERE NOT SURE WHAT THAT
MEANT, AND WHEN WE SAW CHRIS
LAUNDRIE GOING IN AND THAT GOLF
CART SINGING AROUND WITH
INVESTIGATORS WE WERE NOT SURE
WHAT TO MAKE OF IT, DID HE POINT
THEM IN THE DIRECTION?
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING A LOT ABOUT
THE WATER LEVELS THAT HAVE GONE
DOWN IN THE 24 HOURS THAT LED
INVESTIGATORS TO THE DISCOVERY
TODAY.
AGAIN, A BACKPACK AND A NOTEBOOK
BELIEVED TO BE BRIAN LAUNDRIE'S
NEAR THE HUMAN REMAINS, NOT
MAKING AN IDENTIFICATION AT THIS
POINT, DANA.
>> Katie: LAURA, KATIE
PELLETIER, WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE TIMELINE AND THE
EXCRUCIATING WAITING THAT THE
FAMILY AND OUR FRIENDS IN HER
HOMETOWN HAVE BEEN GOING
THROUGH, GABBY PETITO WAS
REPORTED MISSING BY HER FAMILY
ON SEPTEMBER 11TH, IT IS NOW
OCTOBER 20TH, CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON WHAT
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO AT LEAST GET SOME
CLOSURE?
>> YES, WE WERE HERE JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO INTERVIEWING THE FOUR
COPARENTS OF GABBY PETITO, HER
MOTHER NICOLE, STEPFATHER JIM,
HER FATHER JOE WHO LIVES IN
FLORIDA ALONG WITH HIS WIFE
TARA, AND THE ONE CONSISTENT
THING THEY SAID WAS THAT THEY
WERE REALLY HOPING THAT BRIAN
LAUNDRIE WOULD BE FOUND ALIVE.
THEY HAVE QUESTIONS OR WANT TO
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT
CROSS-COUNTRY ROAD TRIP IN
WYOMING AND WANT ANSWERS.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT IF HE IS
FOUND TO BE RESPONSIBLE, THEY
WANT JUSTICE FOR GABBY.
>> Greg: JESSE, I KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION, BUT YOU
HAVE A THOUGHT.
SPEAK TO MY THOUGHT IS THE
PARENTS ARE AS GUILTY AS SIN AND
THEY ARE INVOLVED IN A
CONSPIRACY TO COVER UP THEIR
CULPABILITY IN THIS CASE.
THE GUY COMES HOME WITHOUT HIS
FIANCEE AND THE PARENTS TAKE HIM
CAMPING.
AND ON THE CAMPING TRIP ON THE
WAY BACK, THEY GO BUY
CELL PHONES, THEY ALL GO BUY
CELL PHONES, NOW THE COPS LOOK
AT THE CELL PHONES AND DID NOT
HAVE ANY EVIDENCE, BUT DID THEY
ALSO BUY BURNER PHONES?
A SOLAR CHARGER, BECAUSE IT
APPEARS LIKE THEY WERE IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THIS GUY,
BRIAN, POSSIBLY WITH THE BURNER
PHONES THROUGH THE ATTORNEY, THE
ATTORNEY IS A DIRTY ATTORNEY,
CRICKET OBVIOUSLY, AND IF THE
BRIAN GUY CALLS THE ATTORNEY HE
THEN TELLS THE PARENTS WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH BRIAN, CLIENT
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION, YOU
CAN ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT IT, SO
MAYBE THEY DON'T HEAR FROM HIM
FOR A WHILE, IT'S OUT THERE AND
THE ONE TIME BOTH PARENTS GO OUT
LOOKING, THEY HAPPEN TO STUMBLE
UPON PERSONAL ITEMS, WE ARE
HEARING IT PROBABLY WAS A GATOR
THAT GOT DIRTY LAUNDRIE IN THAT
LITTLE SWAMP, WE DON'T KNOW YET,
BUT THEY COULD HIT HIM WITH THE
CHARGES HERE, YOU HAVE ACCESSORY
AFTER THE FACT IT IS MURDER
COMMITTED ON FEDERAL LAND, YOU
HEARD THE NEWS, THE WORD
MURDERER NOW, KNOWING THE
DEFENSE AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN COMMITTED
RECEIVES, RELIEVES COMFORTS FOR
ASSISTS, THE OFFENDER IN ORDER
TO HINDER AND PREVENT THE
APPARITION TRIAL OR PUNISHMENT,
YOUR ACCESSORY AFTER THE FACT IN
A MURDER CASE IS 15 YEARS OR IS
THERE.
YOU COULD DO HARBORING OR
OBSTRUCTION IF THEY DO SOME
DROID EVIDENCE, AIDING AND
ABETTING, ACCESSORY TO UNLAWFUL
PLAY, I WOULD LEAN SO HARD ON
THESE PARENTS, OBVIOUSLY THEY
KNOW SOMETHING AND HAVE BEEN
HIDING IT, AND THE FAMILY OF
GABBY DESERVES JUSTICE, AND IF
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS, SO BE IT.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> ONE QUESTION, ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PERSONS OF INTEREST, THE
ONLY PERSON WE HEARD PUBLICLY
CONSUMING THIS AWFUL STORY THAT
BRIAN LAUNDRY WAS A PERSON OF
INTEREST, ARE THERE ANY OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT MIGHT BE
TARGETING OR HAVE TARGETED?
>> YEAH, THEY HAVE ONLY SAID
THAT BRIAN LAUNDRY WAS A PERSON
OF INTEREST, AND I DO WANT TO
KNOW TO THAT IN TODAY'S PRESS
CONFERENCE AND ALL THROUGHOUT TO
THIS INVESTIGATION THEY
REPEATEDLY, AGENTS REPEATEDLY
SAID THAT THEY STILL WANT PEOPLE
TO COME FORWARD, YOU MAY HEAR
THE NEWS TODAY AND SAY THAT
THERE WERE REMAINS THAT WERE
DOWN IN FLORIDA, THEY ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO COME
FORWARD.
WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT ALL THESE
WITNESSES THAT SAW THE COUPLE
FIGHT BRIAN AND GABBY ON THEIR
WAY OF THEIR SUMMER TRIP, STILL
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY TO COME
FORWARD AND HE SAYS ALTOGETHER,
BUT TO ANSWER YOU